hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up today
as record energy prices hit consumers
how clean energy will help in the long
run
activists block uk oil terminals
demanding an end to reliance on fossil
fuels
[Music]
and feeding the people boosting
biodiversity the bristol gardener with
one small answer to the climate crisis
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the search for
solutions now it's the day many families
have been dreading the price cap on
energy costs has risen more than 50
percent a rise which will hit everyone
especially those on the lowest incomes
the bad news is that worse is to come in
the short term but longer term there are
solutions paul kelsey reports
britain was facing an energy crisis
before russia's invasion of ukraine
tighten an already historic squeeze on
living standards
as energy prices rise more than 50
percent the boss of britain's fourth
largest provider said worse is to come
price kept going up because you know we
had a global energy crisis
exacerbated by the terrible war in
ukraine
um and in the short term the uk stuck
with these energy prices the reality you
know the way our energy system works is
that you know if
we're not buying russian gas
even if the uk is not buying it it will
be diverted somewhere else
what we need to do as a
society is start to wean ourselves off
gas altogether
in six months natural gas prices have
risen seven times higher than
pre-pandemic but the increase we're
paying today was set in february three
weeks before the invasion of ukraine
caused fresh volatility
prices are forecast to rise even higher
up from today's
1971 pounds for average household dual
fuel use
to 2 600 pounds in october before
falling back to 2041 pounds next april
the government has provided up to 350
pounds in loans and grants to households
but this squeeze won't just pinch the
poor you know one thing we found is that
the number of people who are going to
spend more than 10 of their total
household budgets on energy is going to
soar if energy bills hit 2 500 pounds
this winter we'll have a third of
households paying 10 of their total
budgets on energy bills which is you
know which is a sign of being what's
called fuel stress where you're
struggling with your energy bills
a government energy strategy setting out
plans for renewables like solar and wind
to loosen the grip of oil and gas has
been delayed but we already know we'll
be relying on gas-fired power stations
like this for years to come ending our
reliance on hydrocarbons should be a
virtuous circle delivering cheaper
abundant energy with less environmental
damage and dependence on dictators and
despotic regimes the trade-off is it's
going to take decades
in the short term cutting demand may be
one of the few ways consumers can fight
back if you insulate your home simply
using loft insulation cavity wall
insulation you cut your gas demand by 20
which is a 20 reduction in your gas bill
and that can happen very very quickly
you know in the short term whereas if
you're looking at fracking or north sea
oil and gas that's going to take years
in edinburgh climate protesters mocked
the west's reliance on russia for
millions of families this energy crisis
is very real paul kelso sky news
well let's take a look at our data
dashboard now because as we heard the
amount we pay for power as dictated by
the energy sources we use today we're
using a lot of gas
47
and about a quarter is renewables that's
wind solar and hydroelectric power now
if we look back over the previous 15
years we can see how much this has
changed coal the dirtiest polluter used
to be far and away the most important
source of electricity
as that's fallen away wind power has
risen from nowhere to provide almost a
quarter of our electricity and that's
important because sky news has seen
figures suggesting that the cost of
producing energy from wind will be less
than half the cost of gas this year
falling to a quarter in 2023 so all this
the rocketing price of gas soaring bills
for consumers the falling costs of
renewables will mean an even greater
spotlight on the government's energy
supply strategy it's a plan that we were
expecting to see this week but it's been
delayed well joining me now is our
political correspondent joe pike hello
to you joe pike so first how much
pressure is the government under to help
with the cost of living
a very significant uh pressure kimberly
i think it's only likely to grow as
people really feel the effects of the
change today when
bills start to appear on doormats and in
email inboxes and foreign chancellor he
knows it's not just opposition parties
but some within his own party who do not
think there is enough support his
argument though is that a lot of it's
out of his control you're looking at big
geopolitical dynamics in terms of the
price of oil and the price of gas and
also post pandemic
the uk is not in the strongest financial
position fiscal disciplines what he
keeps on talking about hundreds of
billions of pounds was spent getting us
through covert and therefore there isn't
you know
endless riches to keep spending to help
people out let's touch on some of the
other developments and measures that
came into force today
v80 on energy saving materials like
solar panels heat pumps and roof
insulation will be reduced from five
percent to zero for five years green
technology is now exempt from business
rates saving firms about 35 million
pounds for the new tax year
and you might be able to claim a grant
of up to six thousand pounds to install
low carbon heating systems such as heat
pumps through the boiler upgrade scheme
of course kimberly we don't really know
what is going to happen next certainly
in six months time there will be another
decision on the energy price cap i
suppose it's possible it could rise and
certainly the government have not ruled
out further measures being taken to help
people
if necessary they would though argue
there is quite a lot already they're
doing in terms of council tax rebates in
terms of that cut to fuel duty although
it's only a temporary and a couple of
other things too
okay joe and weren't we supposed to hear
from the government on their energy
supply strategy this week
yes well the government sources can be
now say it's pretty likely highly likely
next week and what is fascinating is how
uh vladimir putin invading ukraine has
completely changed the international
conversation around energy security that
is now at the top of the political
agenda in many countries including ours
the big commitment sounds like according
to reports a commitment on a nuclear the
uk government will want a quarter of the
uk's electricity needs to be nuclear by
some day possibly around 2050 so really
ramping up uh nuclear energy production
in this country not necessarily popular
with people who don't necessarily want
nuclear reactors
near their homes
wind onshore wind is a bit controversial
within the conservative party that's an
easy quick way of ramping up energy
production but there are people for
planning reasons local community reasons
who are not that keen on wind farms and
a lot of them are in the conservative
party boris johnson
realized not a lot of his backbenchers
are keen but also don't forget about oil
and gas we heard in the last few days
that that a license for the cambo oil
field off the
coast of shetland
north of
the scottish mainland that license has
been extended that's pretty uh
controversial and all of this is
different uh the whole dynamics are
different because of what's happened in
ukraine
okay joe thank you so much joe pipe for
us there in westminster
right well let's have a look at some of
the day's other climate use now an oil
terminals across england suspended
operations this morning after
environmental activists blocked roads
supporters of just stopped oil and
extinction rebellion began blockades at
oil refineries around london birmingham
and southampton by climbing on top of
tankers and gluing themselves to road
services they're demanding the
government agree to halt all new
licenses for fossil fuel projects in the
uk and have vowed to continue disrupting
the uk's oil infrastructure until they
agree
and the importance of wild salmons being
highlighted in an exhibition to mark the
queen's platinum jubilee at balmoral
castle
the installation called salmon school
consists of 250 mirror glass forms
suspended in the air the exhibit aims to
raise awareness about the importance of
salmon conservation as climate change
and biodiversity loss threatened their
existence in the wild
salmon conservation has been supported
by the queen the balmoral estate works
closely with the river d trust to help
protect the endangered fish
the government is introducing a new tax
on any plastic packaging that doesn't
contain at least 30 percent recycled
material it was first announced in 2018
to encourage firms to be more
environmentally friendly it will apply
to businesses producing or importing 10
tons of plastic or more a year
an important habitat for a rare bird
species may have been damaged by
wildfires this week sleep bay an area
straddling both northern ireland and the
republic of ireland is an eu-protected
habitat and home to the endangered hen
harrier there have been two fires in the
area in the past few days coinciding
with the start of nesting season which
means that nests that have already been
built will have been destroyed
now making the transition to a
plant-based diet is one way an
individual can help stop climate change
in our latest climate diary we head to
bristol where urban gardens are serving
a dual purpose
so we're gonna plant out these rocket
seedlings into this no-dig bed
which is really easy all you need to do
is pop your fingers in
and plant the plant and then give it a
really good firm in
and we'll water that in a little while
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
bristol is quite a
wealthy city or people have that kind of
expectation of it but the reality is 25
of children are always at risk of food
poverty all of the food that we grow in
any of the gardens that we've helped to
support is available to anybody who
needs it or wants it
and they can just come along and help
themselves in these gardens the food
goes directly into the bristol food
clubs
which supports young families
effectively who are
you know having problems accessing
affordable food
[Music]
gardeners are
increasing biodiversity because they
establishing plants that support
pollinators
they are improving the hydrology of
the land on which they live
because by by reducing areas of
tarmac concrete and so on they they're
releasing those areas to to the rainfall
and allowing infiltration of rainfall
more effectively into the soil
so plants are doing all that and of
course they are taking in carbon dioxide
and then producing oxygen so producing a
healthier environment
we're getting straight into discussing
the climate issues of the day with the
climate and industry lead at the tuc
mika mineo paluello and the
editor-in-chief of business screen james
murray hello to you both thank you so
much for joining us now energy prices
have soared to record levels
what does this have to do with climate a
lot in short the less energy you use in
your house the less impact you have on
the climate and the lower your bills
let's look at these connections a bit
more and we have a couple of questions
from sky news viewers um which you mike
and james will might be able to help us
with but first
can i get a top tip for you on how to
save energy miko do you want to go first
i feel like a lot of people have already
been trying to do this over the past
year they've already done most of the
things that can be done you know turning
down thermostats wearing and wearing
extra jumpers martin lewis has said well
there isn't one
ultimately it's up to government at this
stage if you've got the money then
insulate your home the people who've got
the resources wonderful to put that into
insulating home to reducing and reducing
how much gets used but the majority
can't afford that at this stage
james what about you what's your top tip
um i think i'd echo that i mean it
depends on your circumstance if you have
the money the fact the way that bills
have gone up and the cut in v8t that's
just come into effect today and the new
grant scheme for heat pumps means that
all these technologies that are already
quite attractive are now really
financially attractive they'll save you
money quite quickly solar panels
insulation heat pumps so if you are
sitting on some savings you know you'll
get a better return on that than you
would sitting in a nicer and that
becomes a financially sensible and an
environmentally beneficial thing to do
but of course the tragedy of this
situation is millions and millions of
households do not have savings or they
might be living in homes where that's
not appropriate and that's why you're
seeing businesses civil society trade
unions and environmental groups all
saying exactly the same thing which is
the government needs to do more as
other governments have as we've seen the
french government the german government
comparable economies are trying to do
more to protect people from these price
rises absolutely such a worrying time
we'll get to that that that in a moment
but let's have a look at the first
question we have graham sent it in and
he has asked why have electricity prices
risen that the way they have when
suppliers say that it's from renewable
sources mika
so a lot of our electricity still comes
from gas and ultimately because of the
way our energy system is structured the
market way it's structured means that
even if your electricity is coming from
wind
the price is set by gas and that points
to how iron how our energy system as a
whole is bus that we're told for years
switch supplier and you'll get this
outcome and ultimately that was all nice
and good but right now in the crisis
whoever you've switched to pretty much
your bills are going up wherever it's
coming from and that means we need to
change the system as a whole and it's
fundamental change
we would say that public ownership
should play a significant role that
gives more more control more ability
we're seeing than a lot of the rest of
europe
we could have that here too
okay james what do you think to what
graham asked i mean much the same
unfortunately the way the market is
structured means that the gas price
effectively sets the price you can you
can t you can tweak it down a little bit
the more renewables you use but
ultimately the the unfortunately the gas
price and that's a wholesale gas price
an international gas price if you will
it doesn't matter how much we import
from russia compared to others
that shock will just feed through into
the system and it pushes up the price of
renewables as well as um gas so there
are people looking at this they're
looking at how we can structure the
market differently so that the the
lowest cost marginal form of power which
is almost invariably renewables can have
a bigger impact on the overarching price
but unfortunately um it's that that sort
of long-running work that takes a lot of
time and as we stand gas is setting the
price and gas is very high and very
volatile that's the other really
worrying thing here it could get worse
um if the ukraine situation continues to
deteriorate you could see further
pressure on prices right because the
current rise in prices doesn't even
reflect what's happened in ukraine does
it
no not as yet no i mean the worrying
thing is that the price cap's going to
get reviewed again in autumn it could go
higher still we're seeing the kremlin
saying they could turn off gas tax
exports to europe all together in
response to the sanctions we're seeing
the ukrainian government quite rightly
say please ramp up the sanctions to
include oil and gas and please could you
stop importing it because it is funding
uh putin's war machine so you know there
is a very real risk of it it going
higher and it depends on that
geopolitical context
mika when you say we need a fundamental
change in the market is that the
international market you're looking at
or the local market and how we're
structured in here how would you change
it and how long do you think it would be
to bring about that change
so i mostly mean in the uk because
that's where the government has the most
power and ultimately what we have now is
a market that was designed created
in the 80s and 90s and as i said it's
bust it's failed it's failed to deliver
secure and affordable energy
there's a significant role for public
ownership of energy instead of this
whole switch from one supplier to
another supplier actually having
supplies whether they're locally owned
by councils nationally providing that
affordable energy government can choose
to keep it the way it is which is
ultimately
serving mostly richer people or provide
a solution for everybody now that is
something that we need that's
transformational but you're right it
won't help tomorrow and that's why we'd
say the chancellor should come back now
with an emergency people's budget we
he's he did that during covert it's
perfectly feasible for him to come back
next week maybe we'll take him two weeks
come back we've revised proposals where
he lays out how he will increase
universal credit increase boost pay
boost pensions but also provide
the immediate relief that's needed to
the millions of families being driven
into poverty by the energy price hikes
and the money is available right we
heard earlier from from your your
reporter that
sunax is not sure where to find the
money well actually we're seeing oil and
gas companies raking in billions and
billions in profits because of the war
in ukraine because of the misery that
people are being pushed into from these
high bills there's a direct transfer
even from people on minimum wage of
hundreds of pounds
to these companies who are profiteering
now actually it's perfectly fine to have
a windfall tax on those companies
pensioners the pension holders who are
in a small proportion of the universes
would still be getting high returns and
that could then be redistributed through
the warm homes discount other mechanisms
to the people who are in the largest
poverty it's the chancellor has the
choice right now whether he wants to be
a poverty chancellor or bring us an
emergency people's budget it's a choice
but he's not making it
okay um james i want to pick up on a
question a point you made earlier
because that does tie into the second
question we have it was sent in by an
anonymous sky news viewer have a look at
this why is the rise in energy price
here
higher than in europe james
um i mean there's a couple of reasons it
varies based on which market you're
looking at the
part of the bill is
part of the bill here is to pay for uh
green levees that fund energy efficiency
schemes and renewables contracts and and
the warm home discount and other grant
schemes uh in germany they move quite
quickly to take those type of levies off
of the bill so that reduced the bills a
bit there uh they've also just gone in
and provided more direct funding support
to kind of to to keep the bills down in
a sort of quite a statist way that some
would argue
is not necessarily beneficial in the
long run but it has held down prices in
france and germany uh in in a way that
it hasn't here uh the i mean the other
thing to say about a lot of these
countries is the uk has some of the most
inefficient housing and and office
buildings in europe uh even though we're
a northern european country even though
our climate is quite cold as we're
finding this week uh we have some of the
draftiest and dampest and coldest
country buildings in europe and we've
had that for decades and other
governments have done a lot lot better
at providing incentives and direct
funding uh and and tax breaks that have
encouraged people to improve their homes
over time uh made it more financially
attractive for them to do so and as a
result their buildings are more
efficient which means you're using less
energy which means your bills are lower
means that when you have a shock like
this it's easier to absorb
and we over decades have consistently
failed to do that and as a result
when prices go high that becomes a
serious problem because we use so much
energy in our homes
okay just we've got about 30 seconds
here half a minute do you think that
it's such a
dire time whether you look at what's
happening in ukraine or the energy
crisis here the cost of living crisis do
you think ultimately though some good
could come out of this
in that in the long term we will move to
cleaner energy yes and like the time is
now the chance has taken the government
has to act and this is an opportunity
it's a disastrous situation we're in but
let's say the government comes out and
rolls out an ambitious insulation
program led by councils that could slash
bills could reduce dependence on gas
reduce putin's power could create
hundreds of thousands of jobs it would
create a better future for us now in the
immediate term also for uh for our
children for our children's children for
future generations create a healthier
society it's entirely possible and now
is the time to sit for government to act
okay mike james thank you so much have a
fantastic weekend
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now
there it is you can listen to the latest
edition of the sky news climate cast
today's edition anna jones speaks to
karen isaac who's being pushed into fuel
poverty because of those rising bills
our science and tech editor tom clark
tells us what lies ahead in the energy
crisis
you can subscribe now wherever you get
your podcasts
well thank you so much for watching see
you next time
[Music]